[Music]
during the dc fandom digital event in
late august 2020
warner brothers released the first
trailer for the batman the upcoming 2021
feature that stars robert pattinson as a
younger even broodier dark knight
while the trailer doesn't give much away
seeing how only 25
of the film was shot before the pandemic
halted production it's peppered with
numerous clues and at least
one big secret tease that possibly hints
toward a grander conspiracy
the batman writer director matt reeves
hinted at such when he spoke at dc
fandom
teasing that the film will peel back the
layers of batman's origins and take a
closer look at bruce wayne's family
particularly what role they played in
gotham city declining into corruption
you start to see that as it starts to
describe this epic history of corruption
in gotham
that you start to understand well where
did my family sit in that
reeves statement revealing that the
movie will touch on bruce wayne's
origins and question one involvement his
family might have had in corrupting
gotham in the first place has set the
internet ablaze with a mind-blowing
theory
while there's almost certainly some
degree of misdirection going on if you
take the batman trailer at face value
there are several big takeaways
presented
one the riddler is the central
antagonist and he seems to be taking
things a little bit more seriously this
time
does anybody else feel like a pride egg
two this is a younger angrier bruce
wayne still learning the ropes of this
whole being a vigilante thing
and three the riddler for whatever
reason is not only leaving clues for the
batman but also creepy personal messages
foreshadowing a personal vendetta that
seems to be a mystery for even bruce
wayne
from here many fans have theorized that
a deeper conspiracy is afoot one that
revolves around the riddler potentially
knowing far more about the batman than
he lets on
there's some basis for this in the
comics the riddler is often presented as
a brilliant but socially awkward
manipulator who plays people like chess
pieces
albeit in weird ways in the storyline
hush he deduces batman's secret identity
so what if he's done the same thing in
the batman
what if the riddler knows bruce wayne as
batman using that information as a
motivator in his twisted games
well if this ends up being true in the
batman the classic narrative of the
riddler leaving clues out of an abstract
intellectual desire to match wits with
an equal might be completely offended
furthermore if this theory is correct
then the riddler isn't just leaving
riddles to tease bruce about knowing his
weird little nighttime habit he has
bigger ambitions
what ambitions though as a number of
eagle-eyed fans have noted the trailer
for the batman depicts the riddler
leaving batman a card with an owl on the
front
and that points them to another area of
the wayne's lives that the riddler might
know about how did you figure this out
the batman has consistently been
described as more of a noir-inspired
mystery film than the character's
previous movies
with that framework in mind every clue
matters the choice to use owl imagery is
probably not an
easter egg but rather a clue toward the
involvement of the court of owls a
secret society comprised of gotham's
wealthiest leaders businessmen and
politicians
in the comics the court of owls have
spent centuries controlling gotham's
underbelly enforcing the wealth
inequality crime and corruption
that make the city so infamous now
remember what reeves said before
regarding batman being forced to
question where his family sat
in gotham's history of corruption the
odds are given all this that the waynes
have a bloodier history than bruce's
parents might have ever told him
and while the comics have generally
depicted thomas and martha wayne as
being charitable and decent figures
whom the court of owls directly opposed
the same might not be true in this film
it's entirely possible that they may
have even been members of the court of
owls or perhaps supported the
organization's goals knowingly or
unknowingly
alternatively their opposition to the
court's corruption might have
in this movie at least directly led to
their deaths it's got of course you know
action all that kind of stuff but at the
end of it
it also is incredibly personal for him
even though it is the story in which
he's trying to understand and unravel
this mystery
either way the riddler's statement that
you're part of this too implies that the
entire goal of his puzzles might be to
force bruce wayne to confront his
family's dark past
and if this hypothesis actually proves
accurate it still remains to be seen
where the riddler stands on all of this
is he serving the court of owls for
instance or trying to take them down
who knows all of this might be wrong
anyway in the meantime it's fun to
speculate
what does it mean it's a riddle
the batman hits theaters on october 1st
2021.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one